the picture I had in my head was the
ladder remember the ladder right so
we're at the top of the ladder right now
here I am and I can see it in terms of
what's the next step down hi n minus 1
right and if I went down another step I
could see I n minus 2 and so on
eventually I should get to some I may be
I 1 or I naught which I can actually
just integrate rather than some awful
mess like this ok
so I start at the top what's it equal to
well it's this this right that's me
looking at the next ladder down ok the
next rung of the ladder I should say so
when I put in n minus 1 everywhere I see
em what happens numerator should be a
minus 1 this is denominator that n minus
1 that minus will cancel with plus 1
right so you get M plus n yes and then
you can see the next rung down okay now
we've got to establish a pattern here
generally three steps is enough for
patent yeah
because otherwise if I give you two
steps you don't know whether the next
number is three or whether it's for it
could be an AP or GPA right so you need
that third step to establish it and
people were sort of trying to be quicker
I think and we're running out of time
but you have to have that number of
steps so you've got n minus 2 M plus n
minus 1
and then you've got the next one down
okay there you go
that's enough steps patents established
I can see what's happening to the newer
in the denominator cool I'm gonna skip
to now where should I go but it's a safe
value to go to I think over your minimum
value is two but I think your second
value is three because again I'm looking
for a set of three and I know it might
be something which breaks the pattern
okay it's gonna be an integral that I'll
need to evaluate right so here's what
I'm gonna do
I've three what happens in here well
it's this but with threes in it
right so this is what you should get
you've got n on top then you've got M
plus n plus 1 that's 4 yeah and then I
can see the next run down
next one okay these are all reducing by
one unfair right so you got two on M
plus three and then I see the next room
down okay so my pattern is establishing
here okay now at this one you've got two
signals that you know what to do here
right the first signal is the pattern
cannot continue it doesn't work for my
lord right
because if you put zero out here it's
just everything zero okay secondly this
figured out what I know it would be
what's our definition for i N
it's all this stuff right so I can value
I can control or
I can evaluate that one is when n is
zero right so this is what you get eyes
eros equal to and you say the integral
not using the recurrence relation
anymore okay so you've got X to the VM
out the front and there's your end right
there okay so that's good
that's just X to the M so what do we get
here that's going to be n plus 1 n plus
1 from normal to 1
yep so what do I get that'll be 1 on n
plus 1 minus 0 so there you go there
right there that's final ok so now I've
got all the rungs on the ladder now and
only now can I put together some people
what they did was they said ok
Here I am and then they had they tried
to build the recurrence in here right
but invariably they forgot these guys
you need these guys they're the end of
the ladder right you haven't established
where they aren't the product that I'm
about to write I haven't established
where it ends unless you've done these
ok so now we can put the whole thing
together right here's what I've got all
of these numerators all multiply right
so on the top I'm gonna have n n minus 1
and minus 2 now I can say dot dot dot
which corresponds exactly to this dot
dot dot right times 3 times 2 times 1
there you go
okay and then I've got another one
donate for this last time so I multiply
by one again okay now what's on the
denominator where do I start
I stop there I go down I go down again
and now because I've established a
pattern I can say I don't doughnut okay
where do I finish well it just so
happens that I can see this pattern here
actually still is preserved right so to
get the last three steps I can just say
this 3 2 1
there you go okay so what do you do with
that how can I use factorial notation
and it's not it's not a hard one to
simplify this well numerator first
that's an easy one right you start from
it you go all the way to 1 so what's
that cool ok that's easy but when you
have a look at the denominator he starts
at this number
any starts going down like a regular
factorial does but it doesn't go all the
way down to the end it doesn't go all
the way to 1 right so it's like this but
it's missing some times how many terms
is it missing right well just in case I
think some of you can see it but I think
the abstract numbers make it a bit
harder to see if for example I gave you
this right which would be a typical sort
of thing from arrangements okay you can
see this starts off like 10 factorial
okay but it's missing what is it missing
he it would be 6 times 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1
that was what will complete the 10
factorial but I know I know what that is
I have a way of writing that 6 times 4
times
one that six factorial right and it's
not there it's missing so I divide by
that right so in exactly to say where I
look at I see how many terms are missing
off the end of my M plus n plus 1
factorial and the answer is n factorial
is missing okay because that's that's
right but that's division on the
denominator so all you really need to
say is that to put it on the right time
and that's all that's it that's as
simple as it gets you can't really do
anything else apart from that okay any
questions
I don't remain you particularly wanted
to see this was there which which step
was the crucial one for you which was
the hardest part
okay um yeah you would have you could
still do that factorial and talk with
you yeah yeah yeah this this step here
well I think there's there's kind of
three pieces to this right constructing
the ladder if you like you've got the
top of the ladder then you've got the
bottom of the ladder and then you've got
the well if you like you call that the
ground which has to be done in a
different way you've got to do an actual
integral right but then once you've done
that you can put it all together
there's your product and it simplifies
out quite nicely all right excuse me
thank you run um you don't well now I
need you to have a look through your
payment now that we've gone through all
the questions and make sure
oh I didn't say where I put those marks
sorry I should do that let's see here
for integration by parts there was only
one mark on this first part right one
mark yep so the one mark was really just
here choosing an appropriate U and DV
and putting them in it's not enough to
have an appropriate un DV just on their
own you've got to actually put them into
integration by parts there's one mark
part two
the two marks where did they go aha okay
this step right there this manipulation
that's hard
this here is just is nothing dramatic
you don't need to be able to see
anything particular but this is tricky
okay there's one the other step was the
other purpose here evaluating the
integrals right or rather put it in
terms of your capitalized so that you
can get rid of your integral terms so
there's two months their last bit okay
the first mark was for these parts of
the ladder right so you need the top
ladder the bottom of the ladder if you
only got the top you lose that whole
mark you don't get half amok that's the
way it works in the HSC right one mark
there one mark for evaluating I naught
and then the final mark was or I think
if you got up to here even if you didn't
put the N factorial over the right spot
if you identified all the factorials
then I thought that was enough and I
gave you the third mark